le pouvoir du cheval chez l'homme ça va
être de révéler cette intelligence
émotionnelle qu'on a tous
[Musique]
l'idéal est pas de droit elle est d'un
patient que j'accompagnais en
hospitalisation en soins psychiatriques
c'est un patient avec lesquels on se
posait pas mal de questions comment le
faire sortir quelque part de
l'institution et c'est lors d'une sortie
programmée par l'équipe on est venu à
rencontrer des chevaux et le patient
s'est jeté sur un des chevaux et du coup
de là je me suis dit il ya quelque chose
à faire entre le cheval et les soins il
ya forcément un point de rencontre
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous attendez un de
l'équithérapie qu'est ce que vous
attendez de moi et qui pense la chose
qui m'intéresse le plus c'est de rentrer
en relation avec le cheval que c'est
quelque chose qui peut me paraît riches
et pas avec les mêmes enjeux les mêmes
difficultés que
d'établir une relation avec un humain ça
va beaucoup plus vite c'est un très beau
coup plus instinctif et sur le contact
d'être dehors france est
différente d'une thérapie non dans un
bureau face à face
à tommy
ce qui m'attirait dans la pratique de
l'équithérapie c'est de pouvoir
accompagner dans le soin mais dans un
milieu complètement normalisée ici on
est en centre équestre et donc les
personnes sondées personnes se sont pas
des malades ne sont pas des patients
pensent qu'il est calme et à la fois il
attend aussi de pouvoir bouger un peu
plus d'accord
[Musique]
dans une séance il n'y a pas réellement
dangereux il ya uniquement le plaisir de
la rencontre pour la personne en fait
que je vais travailler en séance ça va
être de réveiller vraiment le sensoriel
parce que réveiller le sensoriel ça a
révélé l'émotionnel moi je suis là pour
mettre en mots
la personne avec cette mise en amoureux
et ce qu'elle ressent ça va permettre de
donner du sens un petit peu à ce qui lui
arrive de restituer son histoire et
finalement de se réapproprier son corps
de se réapproprier sa vie donc tout à
l'heure dès le début de la séance vous
parliez de cette mise en mouvement est
ce que la ceni en mouvement qui répond à
vos attentes
ouais est ce que vous seriez dire
pourquoi
il ya une situation en sciences qui m'a
marqué j'ai eu
une personne qui m'avait contacté suite
à un deuil c'était très difficile pour
elle de verbaliser ses émotions et elle
s'est mise à pleurer et en fait le
cheval qui était arrivé au bout du
manège a traversé tout le manège est
venu poser sa tête sur son épaule le
pouvoir du cheval chez l'homme ça va
être de révéler cette intelligence
émotionnelle qu'on a tous je pense
notamment aux personnes qui peuvent être
autiste ou non verbaux qui vont quand
même réussir à entrer en relation à
créer une relation grâce justement à
cette mobilisation de l'intelligence
émotionnelle qu'on a
alors comment vous vous sentez
je me sens très calme n'a pas rapport à
mon état de basses au début j'étais pas
du tout sûr de moi parce que je connais
pas ce mode de thérapie au fur et à
mesure je pense que j'ai pris confiance
que j'ai aussi compris comment doha
travail et à la fin de la séance j'ai
été très détendu très apaisé
avec une prise en compte de mon
environnement qui est un peu inhabituel
chez moi et et si j'avais plein d'idées
en tête de choses qui me faisait
réfléchir et
j'étais très intéressé ça donne envie de
continuer à siffler
l'équithérapie du côté du milieu
thérapeutique est plutôt bien reçus on
travaille notamment collaboration un
petit peu avec les au thérapeute a donc
ça se démocratise de plus en plus et
puis le coc vide et ans a apporté quand
même aussi un petit peu de positif ça a
permis quelque part de se dire ok on
peut plus sortir on est confiné
maintenant dans les institutions il ya
quand même des personnes malades des
personnes qui ont besoin de soins et si
on peut plus les faire sortir alors
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas faire entrer
des animaux et c'est dans cette démarche
que il ya pas mal de collègues qui
thérapeute justement qu'ils font rentrer
les chevaux en maison de retraite
[Musique]